that's right everybody now to accept
this challenge first like on the phone
yeah you know what let's not smash like
on many buttons
let's give sensual loving tonight button
I don't know by you guys but I've been
educating myself i watch the Gillette
commercial and just let's make sweet
love to the light one thanks right
that's how you accept this challenge
now let's frickin go I'm so ready got it
Howard's awful this is the greatest
video I have ever taken
sorry I I went too fast for me to
process what is happening this is like a
conference why is she doing a fortnight
Dames old buyer oh it gets it's one of
those that gets better the more you
watch okay
what is happening I am so confussed
maybe some things are better not knowing
the context some things box moving on oh
god another Spiderman meme huh
I miss Toby Tallyho
watch out spider-man Pizza time
oh my god god damn it I don't know if
I'm happy or disappointed I think I am
both end up in Skyrim every time every
goddamn time I end up in Skyrim great
babe you know what I can appreciate it
even though I lost in life stop laughing
you idiot pathetic I'm out of G fuel oh
my freaking gosh I'm out of J feel I
could die
no cheating this time boys let's freakin
go
[Music]
okay hey all right you know what leaves
now I can laugh at it it's so annoying
if we're so long I mean I don't laugh at
it because my health is still intact
look at my help screen what is happening
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this man cannot take any bad words okay
maybe I should take a break for a while
I'll relive some of my greatest moments
no gotta say this is a pretty legit
memes this week smash like no that was a
test
sensual loving frickin Germany
I'm not even trying at this point
because I want to die ah geez guys I'm
down to one health
oh god is spider bags
you seem very okay
the crossover it's happening kojima-san
please please I make it happen let's
start the petition told me McGuire for
the next coach it was called deaf
stranding oh my god yes because he hires
a bunch of actors oh my gosh yes Tobey
Maguire for deaf stranding everyone
smashed like summer since you were
loving like on the bun alright whatever
you do this morning one of the mister
Ksenia clear I know they're jailed for
10 years what are you you ugly oh that's
a strange one I'm not sure why I'm
laughing
no you basically what can I say I got a
weak weak spot for dumbass people I
don't know it looks like I'm negative
life everyone well oh well I might as
well go all out just this one's little
yeah
172 two and a half hours and forget
about it
oh my gosh he actually forgot about it
oh my gosh that the moment when you know
you're going to die from you laughs you
lose because you're all out of health
but you still commit to the challenge I
rise today for the awesome and important
duty important duty pay a happy birthday
wish to Garfield not President Garfield
Mike but someone probably more famous in
this day and age than that who could it
be my friend
orange who are you talking about lazy
cat this is why I say give more money to
politicians we are not paying them
enough
oh it's Neil brain we're literally
watching the abrading video yesterday my
movie yesterday oh my god yeah yeah Jim
now how could he image suicide with one
Jim who is he talking to who did he tell
to call them how could you have done
this Jam how could you do believe I
cannot believe you committed suicide how
could you have done this I batted
suicide yeah I can't help you out of
this one Jim you can't can't help you
out of this one meal green the living
legend can't pull you out of this one my
hands are tied a mime sorry I don't know
what to tell you babe I mean he tried he
said call 9-1-1 anytime i made a video
in this movie if you want to check it
out by the way what was a while ago
nothing I think and I just got
- car yeah I'm done this you know it's
easy this is the same guy that was in
the water accordingly katakana me no
koto mo Motorama you're gonna be
Superman Stoney no joke okay all right
you know cooky they give up yes
damn I felt that very nice message never
gear never give up that must be the same
guy
[Laughter]
so bad and so great at the same time we
did it guys we found the best clip yes
I've seen this a million times it's so
good I don't like the caption without
that everything else is so perfect yeah
you know just gets to a point yeah your
life you lose right I lose I basically
lose I admit it okay I've been cheating
every single time I don't know if you've
got this but G fuels doesn't actually
replenish your health guys or does it
can I say that I meant like in a you
life you lose context Oh
alright guys on that note we're gonna
end your life you lose there if we left
you loose and if you lose you laugh so
to smash subscribe and I see you bro
just keeps on the next hole ski now
ready for this ah